we've got the biggest dreams of putting
our eyes on other worlds traveling to
them making them our home but how do we
get there the stars are so far apart we
would need sailing ships that could
sustain human crews over the longest
haul of all time
the nearest star is four light-years
away
that's 24 trillion miles to Proxima
Centuri
just to give you some idea of how far
away that point of light really is if
NASA's Voyager 1 spacecraft which moves
at a pretty good clip 38,000 miles an
hour was headed for Proxima Centuri it
would take 70,000 years to get there and
that's only the nearest star out of the
hundreds of billions in our galaxy
[Music]
so if we want to endure as a species
beyond the projected shelf life of our
own planet we'd better act like the
Polynesians we need to take what we know
of nature and build sailing ships that
can ride the light as they once rode the
wind
[Music]
these sales are enormous miles high but
they're very thin a thousand times
thinner than a garbage bag
[Music]
when a photon of light strikes those
magnificent sails it gives them a little
push
this means that in the vacuum of space
even the tiniest push from a photon will
propel them ever faster until they're
moving at a significant fraction of the
speed of light
when you get too far from your star and
the light dwindles lasers can do the
trick
[Music]
if we were to lightsail our way to
Proxima Centuri it wouldn't take 70,000
years but only 20 years
próxima B lies in the habitable zone of
its star but we don't yet know if it
could support life does it have the kind
of protective magnetic field that has
sheltered the evolution of life on the
surface of our world another consequence
of Proxima bees close location to its
star is that the planet is probably
tidally locked one side perpetually
facing the star the other doomed to
endless night
[Music]
[Music]
you